a large part of what you talk about is
grounded in the reality that men or men
women are women they're different
what do you think this newfound Embrace
of gender activism and gender fluidity
and a man can become a woman and a woman
can become a man and people can wake up
every day and identify as something
different what do you think the goal is
here with people who are really
advocating for that right now the goal
okay so there's the personal level and
then there's sort of like the
socio-political level here I think on a
personal level uh men and women want to
feel special in some way it's no longer
enough to be homosexual to make you
special now you've got to be transgender
to be special there has to be some sort
of something that makes you unique and
there has to be some sort of tribalism
that's attached to that and in order for
that to be effective uh you have to
convince a society at large to play
along with your psychosis and that's
really what it is when we look at how
gender is defined we say you know I've
heard of course you've probably done
videos on the the map documentary on
what is a woman and he goes out really I
I have mixed feelings about that that
documentary simply because it seems like
it's really kind of red meat for
conservatives on some level but on
another level it um it illustrates the
fact that uh the Society Western
societies as a whole have adopted the
language of this woke
um leftist uh idea well it's really
ideal it's really a religion if you
think about it because it has all the
Hallmarks of religion but
um when uh when you look at what it is
founded on it is based on three things
it is based on the blank slate that
everybody's like we're all just blank
slights and everything is social
constructionism and that gender is a
social construct and not a real material
objective biological definition and on
top of that then you've got the
emotionalism aspect of this entire thing
so those are the three like legs of the
stool and if you kick out one of those
legs or all of those legs everything
else comes crashing down so if we're
going to talk about like gender identity
if they don't have the blank slate if
they don't have social constructionism
and if they don't have this role over
Reliance on emotionalism all of their
identity that has been built up to that
point they have to reassess so for
instance when Matt Walsh was on Dr Phil
and he was on there with the the bearded
lady as I call this person I don't know
what to call him him or whatever it is
uh and he's on there having this
discussion about what is a woman and so
he's on there with a bearded lady
transgender man who wants to be a woman
and then you've got the uh the college
professor there who's a gender studies
professor and she's regurgitating the
same kind of intersectional uh wokesey
uh feminist gynocentric uh ideology
she's basically a prophetess of this of
this New Age religion and it is founded
on the idea that gender and identity and
um and and uh well first of all gender
and sex are like are two separate things
whereas if you ask any evolutionary
biologist evolutionary psychologist they
are intimately connected so there is
this conflict I think of this new order
information that is confounding and
conflicting with these ego Investments
that these people have in their own
identities and the only way that those
identities are supported and say afloat
is if people play along and use their
gender pronouns and use that language
and they play along it's kind of like uh
okay uh you know Junior wants to be
Superman or Spider-Man so we're going to
start calling him Spider-Man or we're
going to start calling him Superman or
we're going to start playing along and
we don't want to break character when in
fact we know in the back of our heads
that it's all [ __ ] you know we're
looking at this just thinking we're
playing along with the child and that's
really what we're doing when you placate
to a kid long enough that kid is going
to make demands that kid is going to be
the one who's going to set the the tone
for Authority in in that relationship
between the adults and the and the and
the child and that's really where we're
at right now I think anyways on a larger
social uh narrative so like I said
there's the personal like one-on-one
narratives and then there's the larger
scope of like we're all gonna play along
with this nonsense that uh a woman could
be a man and a man could be a woman
right up until reality smacks them in
the face and we see the what is it the
number
463rd swimmer male swimmer in the world
becomes the number one female swimmer in
the whole world or you see like
wrestlers who are transgender wrestlers
who go into competitions and they
dominate there or you'll see um you know
we have this idea that that women can do
anything a man can do and man can do
anything you know men can be just as
nurturing and be just a mother and
everything else and we so we swap those
roles because it's reliant on one thing
the blank slate it's reliant on social
constructionism so when we say hey uh
you know uh Mr Mom or Dad can be a
stay-at-home dad and be just as
effective a mom as a dad or vice versa
and we glorify single motherhood because
of this idea that you don't need a man
you might want him but men and fathers
become Superfluous when that woman
becomes sort of this androgynous thing
that can fulfill both roles that is what
we have been playing along with since
the sexual Revolution and it has
escalated up to the point where we're at
here in 2022 where we're asking for
objective definitions of what is a man
and what is a woman and the reason why
the bearded lady on Dr Phil could not
answer that question why pretty much
everybody on that documentary couldn't
answer that question is because if they
were to give Matt Walsh a definitive
answer as to this is a man and this is a
woman it fundamentally challenges their
identity that's been built up over all
over this time because if I can say this
is a man and this is a woman and you
ain't it that forces you to go and
reassess your entire identity and that's
not they simply don't want to have to be
forced into that situation they don't
want the truth forced upon them if you
want to watch the full episode you're
going to click right here and if you
want to ask me a question one on one you
want to do a one-on-one face time with a
group of your friends whatever you want
you need to download manect right now
click right here and let's get talking
[Music]